-Now everybody knows
how to play Pictionary.
30 seconds on the clock.
We each take a turn
then we'll have a showdown
where both teams will draw
the same clue at the same time,
worth double the points,
maybe triple the points.
We'll wait and see.
-I've never lost.
-You've never lost?
-No.
-No, perfect, me neither.
This is perfect, me neither.
♪♪
May the best team win.
Shailene, why don't you guys
go first?
Catherine, you can have
a seat there
and wherever
you want to sit down.
-Alright.
I draw a lot of stick figures.
-Okay, that's okay.
-Alright, what number should
she pick, you guys?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-What did you hear?
-Somebody screamed four.
-I think I heard four.
-Number one!
-Five, let's do five.
Okay.
Oh, no.
-Yes, I love the confidence.
-Okay, it's a person,
place or animal.
Do I get to do that?
-Person, place or animal.
-But not exactly those words,
person,
so don't guess person,
place or animal.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
-A mirror? A mirror?
-Unh-unh.
-No? A portrait?
-Uh-huh.
-A Portrait of Dorian Gray?
-Unh-unh.
Disregard the hair,
disregard the hair.
-National Portrait Gallery.
Somebody who likes to get
their picture taken?
-Uh-uh, uh-uh.
-Oh my god a painting.
An art gallery.
-The one before, uh-huh.
-An art gallery?
-Yeah, an...
-Art, art.
-They're talking too much.
-Oh my Lord, I'm so sorry.
-Am I allowed to say?
Mona Lisa.
-Oh!
-Oh, Mona Lisa. Yes.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
-Yes, that's good.
-That doesn't remotely look
like Mona Lisa.
-Eugene, no, stop it, man.
You can't say that,
don't say that.
-I'm so sorry.
-That was great,
it was fantastic.
Mona Lisa's smile,
the big smile.
Well, everyone remembers
Mona Lisa with the big smile.
-Oh, yeah.
-I was just trying
to reference--
-Come on. Who hasn't
heard of that before?
Alright, we're all cool, we're
all having a good time here.
Guys, give me a number.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Oh, here we go.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Alright,
we're going to get this.
It's a phrase,
did I say that?
-No.
-Oh, should have.
-So an animal.
So, it's an animal?
-It's a phrase.
-Great, perfect.
-Phrase.
-Ready. It's a phrase.
Here we go.
-Oh, I think I know.
-Cat.
A phrase.
Cat.
Tongue.
Cat tongue.
[ Laughter ]
Cat, cat tongue. Cat.
-Cat. Cat...
Oh, hold your tongue.
Cat --
[ Buzzer ]
No. Oh!
-You're kidding!
Are you kidding me?!
Cat tongue, cat tongue!
The cat got your tongue.
The only phrase with the words
cat and tongue in it!
Mona Lisa, Mona Lisa.
Cat got your tongue.
-I would have got it.
-A complete nightmare.
-Another 10 minutes,
I would have had it.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness.
-I can't work under
this kind of pressure.
-Well, the cat got your tongue.
Cat tongue.
Gosh, wow.
Catherine, I cleared
that off for you.
Please pick a number
and enjoy yourself.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, I've embarrassed myself.
-You didn't say it had
to be in English.
-We've so got this.
-I embarrassed myself.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Three.
-What?
I'm sorry.
One of you said seven.
-That was your instinct.
-Oh, my gah!
[ Laughter ]
-You're not allowed
to say gah on this show.
-I said gah.
You can't say gah?
Can I say fuleno?
Person, place or animal.
-Okay. Alright.
-Bear with me.
-Alright, here we go.
-I'm here.
-Don't even try to think.
-I'm not, I'm just gonna react.
-Oh, it's starting time.
-Un-huh, starfish.
What's that?
[ Laughs ]
-Whoa, whoa, Catherine!
What the...?
[ Laughter ]
Why are you doing?
-Okay. It's...
-Catherine.
-It's an animal?
-Unh-unh.
-A person? Star.
-Can we blur that out?
-Star Wars.
-Who's that a bad drawing of?
-Star man? Star?
[ Buzzer ]
Star?
[ Laughter ]
-Darth Vader.
-Darth Vader, yes of course.
What was that?
-Darth?
-Well I suddenly forgot
what a gun looked like.
-That's a gun?
-I forgot what a gun
looked like.
-That's what it looks like.
No, that's what it looks like.
-That's not bad.
-That's what it looks
like, right?
-I kind of said that.
-Eugene, that's what it looks
like, right? That was a gun.
-You know, so far cat tongue
looks like I'm a genius.
-Unbelievable.
Alright, good luck, Eugene.
Pick any number.
-Alright, any number.
-Here we go.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Oh, wait.
-He flashed it a little bit,
but I did not look.
-It's an object.
-That's the confidence
I love in my teammate there.
-It's an object.
-Oh, he is recycling.
No, he isn't.
-Okay. Somebody didn't rip
their thing off.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so passive aggressive.
-Okay.
-He knows that someone is me.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
Oh.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Heart.
Apple.
Yeah.
Some time today,
Eugene, would be fantastic.
Oh. Apple ring?
Apple -- What is that?
Apple bracelet.
Apple clock.
Apple time.
Apple watch, Apple watch!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[Indistinct]
-That's what you wanted from me,
right?
That's what we needed.
-That's what you would guess.
-Now we're cooking with gas.
-Oh, here we go.
I'm feeling good, man.
Alright, here we go.
-Are you going?
-What?
Yeah, which one of you guys
wants to draw?
This is the showdown.
-Do you want to?
I mean, I Mona Lisa smile.
-I like drawing, can't you see?
-We've seen your gun, right.
We have to hand this into HR.
Hold on a second.
-No please, please draw away.
-Alright, here we go.
You're over on that side.
We get the same one,
whichever one of our teammates.
I'm just hearing this
from our judges,
this is worth 8,000 bucks.
Whoever wins this,
wins the whole thing.
-Got it.
-Alright, we can do this.
Whoever gets it first right,
wins. Alright, here we go.
Now, which number
do you want, pal?
-Six, I heard six.
-Six, yeah.
-Oh, okay. Okay.
-Okay, it's a phrase.
I didn't hum it.
-It's a phrase.
-It's a phrase?
-Okay. You didn't hum it.
-I did not hum it, no.
I just happened to do that
when I saw it.
-Yeah, yeah, okay.
-No seriously, I didn't.
Alright, ready?
-Okay.
-Alright, here we go.
-Uh-huh.
Talking hand?
-Talking hand.
-Talking head -- hand.
-Talk to the hand!
-Yeah!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, sir.
-I don't know how he got it.
That's how you do it!
-I let you win 'cause you said
you never lose
and I didn't want this
to be the first time
you ever had to lose.
-I have never lost.
-These are real tears.
My thanks to Shailene Woodley,
Catherine O'Hara.
The champ, Eugene Levy.
Everyone knows how to play
Pictionary.
30 seconds on the clock.
We'll each take a turn.
Then we'll have a showdown
where both teams
will draw the same clue
at the same time,
worth double the points.
-Alright.
-May the best team win.
Kevin, why don't you go first?
-I go first?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Let's go back.
-Let's see here.
Alright, Don,
this is a person.
-Okay.
-Kevin Bacon.
[ Laughter ]
-You've got to look
at what he's drawing.
-I'm looking.
Bugs Bunny.
-Bugs Bunny?
-What am I looking at?
-I don't know.
-Statue of Liberty.
-Beyoncé? No.
[ Laughter ]
Sounds like...
-Let's see.
-Oh, my God.
Shh! Be quiet.
I'm concentrating.
Oh, that's a smile.
It's a --
Oh, a bass player.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, my God.
-Oh, no!
-I have no -- It's a stand-up
bass player.
-I suck.
-Who is that?
-It's King Kong.
[ Laughter ]
-That's pretty good.
-No, it's not good.
-Well, now that we know
what it is, it's good.
-It's obviously not good.
-Now that we know --
Now we know what it is,
it's good.
It's King Kong.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's fantastic.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-Uh, Okay. Which number?
-Sorry, dude.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Why is everyone saying three?
That's weird
that everyone said three.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. This is a place.
-It's a place.
-Yeah.
-Alright.
I believe in you.
-More like a thing, kind of.
-Oh, God.
-Yeah.
-Alright. Ready?
-Yes, I'm ready.
-Here we go.
-Alright.
It's great so far.
[ Laughter ]
That -- I have no idea.
Oh, that's a building?
-Uh-huh.
-In --
-Shh, no words.
-Yeah, good point.
-A building.
A leaning tower.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Audience groaning ]
-What other leaning tower
would there be?
There's not two leaning towers!
-No.
-There's not -- Oh, my God.
Pizza. Pizza. Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughter ]
Come on!
Judges, you're the worst.
You just should've said
"Ding, ding, ding"
when he said leaning tower.
There's no other leaning towers.
-[ Grunting ]
-Sorry, dude. Oh, my gosh.
[ Audience shouting ]
-It's not okay.
-We'll get it, we'll get it.
-Alright, six. Good.
-Thank you.
-Oh, man.
Alright.
-What is it? What is it?
-You give these --
This is an action.
-Action.
-But I don't really think so.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-That doesn't make --
Confusing thing to say.
-You should see this thing.
-Yeah.
-Alright. Here we go.
You ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-Drawing. Swimming.
Surfing.
Diving.
Sea birds.
Bird flying.
Wave of clouds.
A bird wave and fly--
Waves.
That's a wing.
That's a a flying --
"C."
[ Mumbles ]
Something about the birds.
No, it's -- Whoa.
What's going on?
Somebody's peeing.
Peeing?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
-What is it?
-A seagull?
[ Laughter ]
Sea puke?
Oh!
-Yeah, sea puking.
It's sea puking.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a hard one to get.
That's a tough one to get.
You're up, man.
-Sea puke?
-Seasick.
-Seasick, oh.
-Is that an action?
-Sorry. Yeah, of course it is.
-Throwing up is an action.
-Throwing up is --
[ Audience shouting ]
-A condition.
That's a condition.
-Alright.
-I'm still angry.
I'm still upset.
-This is...
-Don't tell me what it is.
Oh, you tell me the idea.
-Yeah. This is an object.
-An object.
Yes. An object.
-Oh, sure, you get an easy one.
-Alright.
-Here we go.
Oh, he's confident.
Taking his time.
It's a train.
No, it's a vehicle of some sort.
Wheels. Road.
You got to do something else,
buddy.
[ Laughter ]
Do numbers --
I don't know if this is legal.
-Four worst Pictionary players.
-Yeah, forget that you did that.
Good, good. Cover up. Cover up.
Oh, it's a train.
Sleeping car.
Sleeping train.
Bunk beds.
Upstairs, downstairs.
"Downton Abbey" on wheels.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
I thought it was "Downton Abbey"
on wheels.
What was it?
-Double-decker bus.
-Oh, double-decker --
-1, 2.
-Oh, I see what you're saying.
Yeah, yeah.
You've clearly never been
on one.
Okay, here we are.
[ Laughter ]
-Do I go again?
-Unbelievable.
Alright. Here you go. Now we
draw at the same time.
Yeah, I think -- I think
you should draw again.
-Yeah, you should go, Kevin.
-Yeah, we'll do --
this guy, yeah.
-Alright.
-Yeah. So we'll just --
Now you guys draw the same clue
at the same time.
Whichever one of us
gets it first...
-We just go.
-...we win the whole thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-What do we win?
-Thanks for coming here.
-What was that?
-What do we win?
-You win a trip to Tuscany...
[ Laughter ]
...in a rental car.
-Oh, great.
-Which one do you want?
-Nine!
-We pick together.
-The audience said nine.
-Yeah, same one, same one.
-10.
-Alright. We got this, buddy?
-What is it?
-They're calling it an object.
-It's an object, kind of.
-Okay.
-Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
He's got to go at the same time.
-Ready?
-Yeah, I'm ready.
-Go.
-Go. Okay.
-Circle. Man.
Standing.
-Big head. Pregnant.
Baby, baby.
-Belly button.
-Butt. Booty.
-Pregnant.
-Nurse.
-Maraca.
What is that thing?
Test-tube baby.
[ Laughter ]
-Hour glass.
-No.
-Drinker.
Drink. Beaker. Drink.
-Drink, drink.
Pregnant. Drink. Cocktail.
-Stomach.
Drink. Cocktail.
Drink. Happy hour.
-Drink.
-A lady!
Ladies' night.
No, drinking.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Audience groans ]
-We're the worst.
-Beer belly.
You guys ever seen
what a beer comes in?
It comes in a --
Martini glass?
-No.
-What's going on?
He drew a penis.
-I saw that.
-You drew a penis.
-You drink the penis,
you get a baby.
I don't know what's going on.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Do we just call it a draw?
-Yeah.
-We're just going
to call this a draw.
You guys, I'm sorry,
that's the way it is.
-That's embarrassing.
-We're all winners.
We're all winners here!
Don Cheadle, you're a good man.
My thanks to Kevin Bacon,
Don Cheadle, my pal Nick Jonas.